any time that you suppress a part of
yourself
it's gonna overflow demi lovato is never
somebody to hold back and she got
extremely candid about her sexuality in
the march issue of glamour
reflecting on her 2020 engagement to max
eric which ended
after two months demi says the
relationship was extremely
eye-opening in terms of her sexuality
saying
this past year i was engaged to a man
and when it didn't work
i was like this is a huge sign i thought
i was going to spend my life with
someone
now that i wasn't going to i felt this
sense of relief that i could live my
truth
demi also spoke about learning about her
sexuality through past
intimate relationships telling the
magazine i hooked up with a girl and was
like
i like this a lot more it felt better it
felt right
some of the guys i was hanging out with
when it would come time to be sexual or
intimate
i would have this kind of visceral
reaction like i just don't want to put
my mouth there
she continued it wasn't even based on
the person it was with
i just found myself really appreciating
the friendships of those people
more than the romance and i didn't want
the romance from anybody of the opposite
sex
and although demi knows how she
identifies herself
she isn't quite ready to share that with
the world yet i know who i
am and what i am but i'm just waiting
until a specific timeline to come out to
the world as what i am
i'm following my healer's timeline i'm
using this time to really study
and educate myself on my journey and
what i'm preparing to do
i'm not living my life for other people
or their headlines or their twitter
comments
bye gosh i
love her you know she is such a force in
this industry she is not only creating
powerful music
but she's talking about really important
things like sexuality
and mental health and by the way i
cannot wait to watch demi lovato
dancing with the devil when it premieres
later this month
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos